c'est néanmoins c'est le pain c'est en
ces termes que telle ou condos s'est
exprimé lorsqu'il a pris connaissance du
projet organisation que nous avons
projeté sur l'île de sa famille chez
millions c'est présomptueux et il est
évident que nous n'allons pas sauvé les
tyrannies la planète en quelques minutes
mais si nous parlons pendant 15 minutes
de la protection de leurs placements
à mon avis j'ai à peu près de 14 minutes
de plus que nous consacrons faire qu'un
d'entre nous à penser à la protection de
l'environnement
tous les jours on n'y pense pas beaucoup
ne vont pas le malin en disant qu'est-ce
que je peux bien fait aujourd'hui pour
son minimum a confirmé pensant à autre
chose nos enfants le prochain à leur
part prochaine juste des passants le
sexe au centre choses humaines lui
pensant à ce que nous voulons il consent
à nous dire
ils'agit sont comment dire sur le plan
personnel
sur le plan individuel et c'est
justement une des vérités plus je
voudrais vous proposer
c'est que l'intérêt personnel n'est pas
égal ou bien cool hein que l'homme face
à son environnement
un comportement parfaitement rationnel
dans le sens darwinien du t1
si vous voulez et qu' il n'y a pas
demandé dimension morale une protection
lors de la marche et que ceci conduit
fatalement malheureusement avec sous
exploitation de nos ressources
ainsi est bien connue de la tahiti des
biens communs lorsque nous avons un bien
commun comme ma mère chacun puise dedans
et
nous avons donc une compétition pour une
ressource minitel qui conduit un conflit
entre un direct l'individu et du bien
commun
avec une conséquence néfaste qui est la
surexploitation des ressources contenues
dans ce bien commun nous avons le cas
avec eux vous connaissiez du temps la
fonte il rappellera les domine tout neuf
en 1960 ce pas son magnifique qui peut
atteindre 500 kg de vivre 40 ans était
ne va rien pas un dollar qui leur est
cher et utilisé on nourrir nos animaux
domestiques
c'est stupéfiant de penser ce que
semaines passent en 2012 a été vendu un
seul poisson sur le marché des studios
avant pour un million de dollars c'est à
ce point la surexploitation de cette
espèce qui est réduite en 2012 a dit
conscient de sa population
comme quoi ce nom il ya 50 ans il ya ce
concert duo et ongles le sud est c'est
la date de la dette écologique c'est les
flots glaner une commençant à emprunter
des hausses aux femmes et aux enfants
autrement dit en 2015
à partir du 13 août et jusqu'à la fin de
l'année nous consommons des ressources
que notre planète ne pourra pas
remplacer
nous vivons au dessus de nos moyens
c'est un principe bien connu qu'en faire
donc
et voilà le développement durable peut
raconter une réponse n est qu il est
capable de résoudre cette inégalité
entre l'intérêt personnel et d'un commun
accord intègre source
nous espérons
environnement avec des technologies
innovantes et une participation de la
communauté
c'est quoi exactement le développement
de la définition c'est que c'est un
développement qui répond aux besoins du
présent sans compromettre la capacité
des générations futures de répondre aux
couleurs il ya en gros trois domaines
d'intérêt le passé - naturelles
d'environnement de passe de - culturel
mais c'est aussi nos communautés
désespoir des attentes
irène nos jeunes leur attachement à la
culture alors haché et puis c'est
l'économie le kamikaze
l'enfant qui n'est pas en soi un bien ou
un mal
les biens willy mal par rapport à
l'usagé que l'on en fait et donc ce
composant permet d'avoir une zone viable
une zone vivable une zone équitable ou
si nous réunissons tous les trois zones
nous avons une zone durable et c'est ce
que nous suivrons dans le développement
durable
c'est devant cette zone devra briller à
l'afp soulevant des climats avec
l'ensemble de ses dettes si l'intérêt et
solutions un imac mais il ya des
contraintes en polynésie nous avons
beaucoup de contraintes et notamment les
moins dix morts 9 idée c'est que c'est
qu'enfin sont également du sac tous et
dans le cadre d'un développement durable
on essaie de profiter de ses côtés en
les convertissant en nature et du
tourisme le développement durable mes
derniers temps à profit cette conversion
du contraire en nature explique si vous
preniez google et vous positionner pour
avoir que du bluff mais que les bleus il
ya eu cette configuration possible
et puis vous regardez
milieu de 10 vous avez la première
française
une fois le plus loin de tous les autres
points du bloc
l'éloignement lits seulement m'insulter
de notre pays et son caractéristique des
finissants celui qui nous dessine une
suisse qui nous dit déterminé c'est
déterminant d'abord sur le plan de sa
biodiversité parce que toutes les
espèces nous sont parvenues à la mi mai
jusqu'ici c'est tellement loin
c'est déterminant sur le plan économique
parce que l'éloignement de l'incroyable
contre 1 pour l'activité économique sont
également déterminants sur le plan
culturel
c'est incroyable peuple qu'il réussit
d'espoir le plus incroyable dans
l'histoire de l'humanité en réussissant
un ami viennent avec les embarcations
trinité à travers l'immensité de la mer
des sites us stupéfiants de coke de 1,6
comment ils ont les ciels faire ça c'est
déterminant aussi donc pour qui nous
sommes et donc on comprend que
l'éloignement
c'est une phase d'une pièce ou en cours
de l'autre côté une incroyable
authenticité culturelle et voter
nationale qui sont des atouts
touristiques indéniables
c'est comme le le national ce calcul est
actuellement sur la station spatiale
la semaine dernière cécile gaspar et moi
avons reçu ce trou où il regarde la
polynésie depuis du globe
la station spatiale et des freaks paris
j'ai eu un volume aux élus il faut vous
êtes aussi éloignés que vous êtes belle
nous avons tous le contrat de ses
contacts et en même temps à un atout
dont côté naturel authenticité
culturelle le véritable agent
changement dans le développement durable
dans le manichéisme
c'est lui qui décide où elle est il a
beaucoup de choix et c'est agissant dans
son intérêt personnel encore en
satisfaisant son désir personnel
nous pouvons orienter son choix vers un
quelque chose qui serait longuement et
là c'est l'infini du développement
durable c'est de faire que ce soit à la
fois un choix personnel individuel pour
notre visiteur qui est en même temps un
choix qui vérifie si à l'environnement
j'ai longtemps travaillé avec un bandeau
sur une vision commune de ce qu'il
conviendrait de faire sur son île nous
aurons beaucoup de débats mais nous
avons été d'accord sur trancheuse
d'abord qu'il faudrait faire appel à la
technologie pour résoudre les problèmes
de logistique et d'infrastructures
sociales
deuxièmement ce souhait très coûteux et
que donc à conséquent il faut réviser
une clientèle fait au légal pour pour
couvrir ses coûts il faut lui donner une
perspective de retour sur investissement
et troisièmement considérant ce
développement et la protection de cette
line qui valait mieux faire notamment
durable c'est en effet un an plus tôt ne
rien faire du tout et l'enseignement
que j'en tire c'est que même le pont
durable et ont rendu possible par la
technologie d écoute écoute à tous les
cons facile ce départ est que en réalité
la protection de l'environnement est un
acte de volonté
ils n'ont pas la négation nous faisons
quelque chose plutôt que de choisir de
ne rien faire ne rien faire des pins à
fait dans la doctrine moderne n'est pas
la meilleure chose à faire pour protéger
un bien en vente à la communauté du bois
d'auch est la première au monde à être
tenant mon énergie renouvelable n'est
pas du goût des mots car dur d'énergie
fossile si ce n'est le gaz est utilisé
en cuisine et c'est pas une source
d'énergie réduisant donc un salaire
grâce à l'énergie solaire à l'énergie 8
du cora et grèce reçoit la climatisation
nous allons finalement nous avons réussi
le gameplay de qualité capone
l'exploitation de cette communauté
et enfin nous allons créer une station
nouveau chef qui a été apportée en dont
un associé et dans le bus et l'éducation
la conservation et la recherche en santé
qui peut recevoir scientifiques et des
chercheurs de partout dans le monde
qu'il faut d'aller sur les sujets aussi
divers cité marine tendu
les poissons dans les poésies
cardiologie et donc lui disons que la
préservation de notre patrimoine
culturel et naturel passe par le partage
entre nous travaux et aussi avec nos
visiteurs
donc nos clients sur d'étirement et voir
ce qui se passe dans la station de
recherche
nous allons faire des mini conférences
et les chercheurs ils sont en cuisine
nouveau secondes les jeunes et sur l'île
pour explorer ce que nous faisons
découvrir un site d'activités de
recherche et donc de petits sont dans la
vie de la communauté des sept nations
voilà à peu près ce que je veux dire sur
le développement durable
s'agissant des terroirs et je remercie
beaucoup là bas